So here is a,
what's referred to as an audio spectrum.
And at the top up here that's a,
a waveform.
That's the actual signal coming in,
that's,
a voltage is a function of
time going into a speaker.
And what this is, this is what's
referred to as a audio spectrum,
short term for a decomposition.
Basically, you've got low
frequency stuff down here,
high frequency stuff down here
with time going that way.
And the question is,
that's a sound, what sound is that?
Obviously, it's the song spectrum.
It's the spectrum of the Prothonotary
Warbler, or, or War, Warbler.
Obviously, I'm not a bird person, okay?
There's a picture of one.
But the idea is, if you listen to this
bird chirp, and then you process it
over time, or actually, you listen to
it chirp over time and you process it,
you would see this audio spectrum.
And the spectra of different birds,
of course, are different.
Here's two different birds,
the Prothonotary Warbler, and
the Chestnut-sided Warbler.
But what you can see is that the spectra
are really quite different, all right?
And, the goal is to think about
these things as what's referred
to as time series, and
how would you distinguish between them.
So, for a given time series,
there are questions you can ask,
like which bird is this, okay?
So like, you've, you've got, you've
got an audio signal, which bird is it?
How long is this thing
going to keep going?
Is this bird sick?
Right?
That is, you know, somehow not normal.
And are there different sort of elements
or different phases that the book, the,
the bird has.
And when you think of these in a time
series context which bird it is,
that's a classification problem.
Time series classification,
how long will it continue,
might have something
to do with prediction.
Is this bird sick?
Would be an outlier detection.
And finally,
you get the notion of segmentation.
So that would be for like bird data.
Well, how about other time series data?
Here's some.
So, you know,
here's stock data of different types of
indices over different amounts of time.
And you might have questions
that you would ask like,
will this stock go up or down?
Something we all want to know.
What type of stock is this?
Right?
If you had a set of
categories of stocks.
And, is this stock behaving
the way it normally does?
And that becomes just like we saw
before, prediction classification,
or outlier detection.
Here's another example.
Supposed you were listening to
the audio of this music, right?
So not looking at the imagery
of the score of, of the,
of the music itself as shown here, but
actually listen to somebody playing it.
You might ask things like, you know,
is this Bach or Beethoven,
which would be classification.
Can we make more of that?
That's now a generative
model kind of question.
And computer music people are always
interested in listening to some music.
Could I have a machine produce
more music of that sort of type?
And can we sort of divide this up into,
into segments?
So this is what's referred to
as time series segmentation.
By the way, this bottom one is,
segmentations receive
a lot of attention lately.
Something called conditional random
field is being applied to it.
We're not going to talk about that,
we're going to talk
about mark-up models.
But I just wanted to point out that you
might not use what we're going to learn
today so much for
segmentation as much as you would for
some of the classification things.